نعود الى الاخبار العاجله التي وضعناها
قبل قليل فقد افاد مراسل الجزيره في
السودان بخروج قياده من النظام المعزولي
من سجن كوبر وعلى راسهم النائب الاول
السابق علي عثمان طه
ومساعدو البشير احمد هارون وعوض الجار
ونافع علي نافع اضافه لرئيس البرلمان
السابق الفاتح عز الدين بينما قالت مصادره
في اسره الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير انه
ونائبه بكري حسن صالح ووزير الدفاع السابق
عبد الرحيم محمد حسين يتلقون الرعايه
الطبيه في مشفى السلاح الطبي حتى هذه
اللحظه
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلمي الكباشي ما معنى خروج هذه
الخيارات الوازله من قيادات المؤتمر
الوطني المنحل
نعم البيان الذي اذاعه احمد هارون نيابه
عن هذه القيادات
ذكر فيه ان الظروف التي كانت في السجن
مستحيل ان يستمرون فيها اذ ظلوا تحت
تقاطعوا النيران كما قال لمده تسعه ايام
وفي ظروف صعبه في السجن لا كهرباء ولا
طعام حتى ان بعض الناس في السجون ماتوا
وبعضهم مرض وظلهم كذلك حتى خرج اخر سجين
وظل معهم عشره فقط من حراس السجن وحينها
قرر هؤلاء الحراس
باتفاق معهم قرروا ان ياخذوهم الى مكان
امن في انتظار ان ياتيهم اذنه قضائي
بالاطلاق صلاحهم او ان يظلوا في هذا
المكان الامن ولم ياتي هذا السجن
القضائي وضلوا كذلك معهم فقط في المكان
الامن ثلاثه من الحراس من العشره الذين
كانوا معهم في السجن واخيرا قرروا ان
يخرجوا لانهم لم يجدوا غير هذا المكان
الذي لم يكن امنا كما قال من حيث الطعام
والشراب والرعايه واخيرا قرروا الاندماج
فيما سماه معرفه الكرامه في مواجهه مشروع
اسري يطيح يريد ان يطيح بالسودان وقال
انهم هم على استعداد الاستجابه متى ما كان
الراي القضاء او نداء القضاء او دعوه
القضاء وعلى كل حال من الواضح ان الحاله
التي نشات على اثر الحرب بين الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني احدثت هذه هذا الذي جرى
لان السجون كلها اطلقت
هنالك اتهامات طبعا بين الطرفين الجيش
اتهم الدعم السريع بانه الطغى سراح
السجناء في سجن الهدى واطلق سراح السجناء
في سجن سوبا وكذلك في السجن النساء
بامدرمان وفي سجن كوبر اذا الان معظم على
خلف العاصمه معظم الذين كانوا في السجون
خارجها واغلقت السجون ابوابها وهذا هذه
حاله الفوضى التي احدثتها هذه الحرب وهذه
تداعيات ليس فقط سياسيه بخروج هؤلاء قاده
النظام السابق من السجن ولكن ايضا
سيكون لها تداعيات امنيه خطيره على امن
الناس في بيوتهم وفي الطرقاتهم وفي
اسواقهم وفي كل مجالات حياتهم على كل حال
هذا تطور جديد في هذه الحرب التي اندلعت
منذ اكثر من 11 يوما وهي ان السلطه التي
قائم الجيش مشغوله ما هي فيه من حرب وان
وقع السجوع وهو
الشرطه التي دائما هي التي تحرس السجون لم
يعد في امكانها ان تسيطر على هذه الحاله
من خلال وقوعها بين ناري المتحاربين ومن
خال اسراء من خلال اصرار بعض او
المتحاربين طرف من المتحاربين اصرارهم على
ان يتخذوا من حاله الفوضى سلاح ضاقت على
الجيش
وحكومته القائمه بالطبع وعلى الواقع
الواقع الاجتماعي الاقتصادي الامني كله
وبالتالي من خلاله يستطيعون تحقيق اهدافهم
في هذه الحرب الان اعلن هو انه سيكونون
جزء من هذه المعركه التي اسماها معرفه
الكرامه في مواجهه مشروعه اسري يريد ان
يطيح بالسودان
وقالوا انهم يستجيبون لاول نداء لهم
للعوده الى السجن او العوده الى
القضاء لمواجهه مصيرهم وعلى كل حال الى
الان لم تستفيد لم تستبين الى الان
الاهداف الحقيقيه او التداعيات والتفاعلات
لهذا لهذا الموقف